well right now a vigil for the little
boy found almost two weeks ago in
mountain springs he is seven-year-old
liam husted
from san jose and that's where teresa
estacio joins us live with this
gathering
of both family and friends teresa
mike anyone hi brian we are here in san
jose and i'm going to get out of the
shot so you can see exactly what's going
on at this minute
the vigil expected to get underway any
minute here at la colina park in san
jose
we're just a short distance away from
where liam lived with his mom
and dad and this is his favorite park to
head to
now balloons are here there's pictures
there's candles
there's notes there's thoughts prayers
all here all for lamb now it was back on
may 24th and liam left his home with his
mom
his mom samantha rodriguez saying that
she was leaving to find them
a new home and then on may 28th a body
was found there in a remote area in las
vegas the identity at the time unknown
until a sketch went out and a friend
recognized liam
liam's mom arrested this week earlier
this week on tuesday
in denver now detectives from las vegas
metro have gone out to denver
to interview her but no motive has been
released but
again this moment this is all about the
little boy
we're learning a lot more about him his
grandfather says that he was kind he was
a sweet child
he had a big heart and he loved to love
his father's here his grandfather's here
many friends and family we're going to
be hearing from them
shortly as you're going to moment as you
can imagine it's a very
very challenging and very difficult
moment i can't even imagine the pain
in everyone's hearts right now but it is
nice to see everyone gathered
and we're going to be hearing from them
shortly
reporting live here in san jose i'm
trista estacio back to you brian
teresa before you go clearly a
well-attended vigil you mentioned the
words of his grandpa
and that the father would be speaking a
little bit later has the father set
anything up to this point as he is in
deep grief
he hasn't he's been very quiet brian
really choosing not to say anything i
mean so much has happened this past week
with the arrest of samantha rodriguez's
you know liam's mom and so many
unanswered questions you know the
autopsy hasn't come out yet we don't
exactly know what happened
and the detectives there from metro have
not really divulged
anything as well we're waiting for the
district attorney's office perhaps to
release some charging documents to learn
a little bit more but
we don't know that much hopefully we'll
hear some words from the father
and of course the grandfather here the
grandfather has been very much an
advocate
lamb had autism and he's been talking
about how
he was just a big-hearted kid and
that all kids with special needs
struggle and
as you well know in this past year with
covid a lot of kids have struggled
mightily so we'll learn more obviously
but
right now it's really just a moment to
pay thoughts
to the family and to support one another
during this very difficult time
theresa we thank you for that report
from the vigil for liam in san jose
thank you